in the last video we stumbled upon a way
to figure out the inverse for an
invertible matrix so let's actually use
that method in this video right here so
i'm going to use the same matrix that we
started off with in the last video and
it seems like a fairly good matrix we
know that it's reduced row echelon form
is the identity matrix so we know it's
invertible so let's find its inverse so
the technique is pretty straightforward
you literally just apply the same
transformations you would apply to this
guy that you to get you to the identity
matrix and you would apply those same
transformations to the identity matrix
and that's because the collection of
those transformations if you represent
them as matrices are really just the
inverse of this guy so let's just do it
so i'll write create an augmented matrix
here maybe i'll do it right here
let me make it a little bit neater
so first i'll write a so it's 1 minus 1
1 and then minus 1 2 1
minus 1
3 4 and then i will augment it with the
identity matrix with 1
0 0 0 1 0
0 0 1.
now if i want to get a into reduced row
echelon form maybe i'll replace the
second row so i'll keep the first row
the same for now so let me just draw it
like this let me keep my first row the
same the entire first row one minus one
minus one it's going to be augmented
with one zero
zero
keep the whole first row the same let's
replace the second row with the second
row plus the first row so minus one plus
one
is zero two plus minus one is one three
plus minus one is two
zero plus one is zero
one plus oh sorry that was a tricky one
zero plus one is one
one plus zero is one zero plus zero
is
is zero all i did is i added these two
rows up now this third row let me
replace it i want to get a zero here so
let me replace the third row with the
third row
minus the first row
so one minus one is zero
one minus minus one is two
four minus minus one is five
zero minus one is minus one
zero minus zero is zero and then one
minus zero
is one
just like that
now what do we wanna do well we've
gotten this far we want to see we want
to zero out that guy in that guy so
let's keep our second row the same
let's keep our second row the same we
write it down here
let's keep our second row the same so
it's 0 1 2 and then you augmented it
with 1 1
just like that
and let's replace my first row with the
first row plus the second row so 1 plus
zero is one
minus one plus one
is zero that's why i did that to get a
zero there minus one plus two
is
one
one plus one is two
0 plus 1 is 1 0 plus 0 is 0.
and now i also want to zero out this guy
right here so let's replace the third
row with the third row minus 2 times the
second row so 0 minus 2 times zero is
zero two minus two times one is
zero
five minus two
times two
is five minus four that's one
minus one
minus two times one that's minus one
minus two is minus three
zero minus two times one that's minus
two
and then one minus two times zero is
just one again
all right home stretch now i just want
to zero out these guys right here
i just want to zero out those guys right
there so let me just keep my third row
the same
let me switch colors
keep things colorful
i'm going to keep my third row the same
so it's zero zero one i'm going to
augment it with minus three minus two
and one
now let's replace
let's replace our first row with the
first row
minus the third row
so one minus zero is one
zero minus zero is zero
one minus one
is zero
two minus
minus three that's 5
1 minus minus 2
is 3
minus 1 is minus 1.
now let's replace the second row with
the second row minus two times the third
row so zero minus two times zero is zero
one minus two times zero is zero
two minus two times one
is oh sorry
i just oh whoops
let me so we said
we have to be very careful not to make
any careless mistakes zero minus two
times zero is zero one minus two times
zero is one it's not zero
two minus two minus two times one is
zero
one
minus two times minus three
that is one plus two times three that is
seven
one minus two times minus two that's one
plus four which is five
and then zero
minus two times one so that's minus two
and just like that we've gotten the a
part of our augmented matrix into
reduced row echelon form this is the
reduced row echelon form of a
and when you apply those exact same
transformations because if you think
about it a series of matrix products
that got you from this to the identity
matrix that by definition is the
identity matrix so you apply those same
transformations to the identity matrix
you're going to get the inverse of a so
this right here is
a inverse
and we have solved for the inverse and
it actually wasn't too painful